because i i haven't look  i have trouble even mentioning  even saying to myself my own head the  number of years i know more think of  myself as being as old as i am than fly  there's not things i don't do now that i  did before whether it's physical or  mental or anything else  that's the polished edited version  that's the best version that 60 minutes  could present of joe biden  people say people say i'm sam  and you can even see it's kind of sad  you can see it in how vacant joe biden's  eyes are he's kind of got that that look  to him that people who are insanility  have he said people say i'm  and i'm not and i'm folk and i'm focused  i could fly  you know and there are things that i  and i don't do things that i did that i  do things i never i don't there's  nothing i didn't do that i do  do shaman  you know you know the thing